thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show we're glad you are
here open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five in the lobby
of Ramsey solutions mark and lorina are
with us hey guys how are you
we're great Dave how are you welcome
where are you from from Cincinnati Ohio
well welcome to Nashville all the way
here in the rainy day oh yeah beautiful
to do a debt-free screen oh yeah how
much debt have you paid off we've paid
off fifty nine thousand four hundred and
fifty four dollars how long did that
take twenty two months why did it go
guys and your range of income during
that twenty two months between 75,000
and about eighty eight thousand good for
you guys very well that's a nice raise
during that time so what do y'all do for
a living
I'm an engineer and I'm a photographer
and I have a boutique at Children's
Boutique very cool and how did your
income go up during that 22 months I
start working a little more overtime
obviously the regular raise and my wife
picked up a few extra jobs and I work
some side jobs and there's anywhere we
could get more money you know whatever
it took to make the needle move oh yeah
so what kind of debt was the fifty nine
thousand well we had a two fairly new
cars we had about five credit cards that
we had transfer balances on and those
were growing student loan mhm
all the normal stuff yeah you're a great
American family I mean you had
everything yep
debt that debt and more debt Wow okay
very cool how long have y'all been
married five years so what happened
about two years ago that caused this
dramatic change in your life because you
guys have gone crazy
yes we did my we had just purchased a
house and my I wasn't very involved in
our finances and we decided that well
actually I walked in on him pacing
around and he was he was in pretty bad
shape so I asked him what was going on
and he told me that we weren't doing
very well financially and that if we
kept up the spending that we had that we
would no longer be
able to make the house payments so when
that happened we said well let's go
ahead and see if we can come up with a
plan and what we can do to make things
better and we really didn't have any
other way that we knew how to do it
because we were using Excel spreadsheets
like a lot of people and we were overall
pretty organized but um we decided we
were gonna take a few days to figure it
out and he and one of his co-workers
actually told him about your your
program and that same day I had actually
seen your advertisement on Facebook and
we talked about it and we said well
let's look into it and we went heading
and got the the home study program and
well we replace your your program with
our movies again we the first 90 days
were some adjustments thank ya figure no
budget was a little hard to get under
control but yeah so Financial Peace
University home study you watch the
stuff at night and then the two of you
put your heads together so mark take us
back to when you're in that room pacing
back and forth melting down and she
walks in and goes whoa you what's going
on yeah well you know in the past I knew
we needed to do something my
spreadsheets just weren't just weren't
doing it so it just came we had lived in
the house for a few months and it was a
bigger house than what we used to have a
lot bigger payment to and with all those
balance transfer cards I was just you
know overwhelmed so it just hit me so I
knew we had to do something yeah and
sounds like she was a helper to you
rather than a thing so but Larina you
didn't know exactly what everything was
I mean you kind of had an idea generally
I'm sure one like he was hiding it he
was just taking care of it
but when you actually sat down and saw
$59,000 how did that feel it felt
horrible I felt responsible for not
being there with him and actually taking
care of it oh dude you married up
but I had it I had no idea that this was
happening because when we met we didn't
put our finances together till we got
married and I had I had $2,000 in debt
when we met so I thought that he was the
same way he seems so organized so when
we realized that that was not the case
we had to make changes so I kind of got
the title of Finance not see when you
got involved you got all the way
involved all right that's awesome
so you went from Netflix to day flicks
that was one of your one of your
sacrifices I hear a bunch of extra jobs
a bunch of new things going on but you
lived yeah lots of people are listening
in right now and they're in the middle
of multiple jobs they're digging out of
a hole with some encouragement you'd
give to them I would say take as many
jobs as you can find that nothing is
beneath you just take whatever you need
to take in order to get out I learned
how to do things that I didn't even know
I could do I started tutoring Spanish
interpreting translating I had
experience and that a little bit before
yeah but I went and got a job at a dance
studio as an admin and making a lot less
than I was used to but it helped us and
we just we just took so many different
jobs he was making salsa and he was
making different foods at work in order
to bring in some I love cooking so
everyone at work appreciates that too
mouths watering I mean I may need tacos
tonight or that is going to go guys so
it's amazing that when you realize that
you can do anything you Raj you're not
stuck that's right you're going to suck
anymore
and claw your way out right yes you can
do it it seems overwhelming at times but
if you put your mind to it
just just hit it and well when you sat
down you saw the fifty nine thousand
twenty two months ago what was it that
you guys looked at that you said this is
going to be really hard whatever this is
but it turned out to be easier than you
probably the going out to restaurants
and then coming up with a monthly
grocery bill you know since I love to
cook it was it was hard to sacrifice you
know mm-hmm I love cooking gourmet
things so I think for me it was the
budgeting figuring out how to actually
create a good budget that will actually
get that will reduce that faster I think
that was a one of the things and we
actually realized that if we made a
specific number every single month and
budgeted on just that anything that we
made over would just go straight to debt
so I think that's what helped us get out
of debt faster very cool very cool well
done yo how's it feel greates amazing
you can do anything can't you oh yeah I
mean you did this you got a Superman
cape on man I mean this is amazing you
got out of that you crate off fifty nine
thousand dollars in debt and you've
never been debt-free while you were
married in the last five years no not
even close no we also had a our daughter
our young a starter yeah during these
two years and uh our deductible is huge
like many of us and we were able to save
up in cash flow that entire deductible
which was an additional nine thousand
dollars it's good to not have a baby
repo yes and I graduated last week with
an associate wanted that um I actually
changed my major I did a liberal arts
and sciences it went is is less
expensive going into my bachelor's of
business with that yeah so we've cash
flowed that I'm we're debt-free with all
right so your baby's names and ages uh
Mia is four and Amelia is seven all
right we're gonna bring them into the
picture for the debt free scream now has
Emile you been practicing her debt free
spring yes four year old four year olds
are generally pretty good at this all
right mark and lorina Mia and Amelia and
from Cincinnati Ohio fifty nine thousand
dollars paid off in 22 months making
seventy-five to eighty five count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one
we're debt-free
did you hear it America I heard it that
is the sound of a family tree being
changed you heard it right here on the
radio who would have thought it
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind